avant dernier jour du somr campe du
numérique un après midi consacré à la
cyber sécurité avec l'entreprise
saint-quentinoise silicone au programme
un exercice d'application avec cet
objectif
s'introduire et prendre le contrôle d'un
autre ordinateur présent sur un réseau
l'enjeu majeur pour nous c'est à la fois
de leur dire voilà c'est possible vous
pouvez rentrer dans cet univers-là il
est intéressant et passionnant mais ça
nous permet aussi de mesurer à quel
point la nouvelle génération qui arrive
sur le marché de l'emploi qui arrivera
sur marché de l'emploi est très capable
de travailler dans ces environnements là
et pas simplement par des cursus on va
dire très classique il ya déjà une
connaissance forte de ses enjeux du
numérique
parce qu'ils vivent dedans et ils sont
bien plus prêts que nous l'étions à
notre époque on retour à la pépinière
d'entreprises promo paul pour le dernier
jour du summer campe le moment de faire
un bilan des dix jours d'initiation à
différents métiers du numérique en
présentiel et en visioconférence les 59
jeunes de 16 à 25 ans ont acquis de
l'expérience chacun dans leur domaine
j'ai appris en fait que la cybersécurité
ce n'était pas que du script etc
s'il y avait aussi pas mal de décryptage
pour moi c'était vraiment le fait de
hacker ou tout autre chose
et franchement non c'est vraiment du
codage c'est très précises tout
simplement haut niveau dans langage qui
s'appelle javascript
je n'avais que quelques bases mais du
coup avec ce stage entre guillemets
c'est vraiment enfin ça m'a vraiment
permis d'élargir également cette option
c'est aussi l'occasion de remettre les
diplômes à tous les participants
le summer camp du numérique un événement
organisé depuis le mois de mai par saint
quentin en yvelines en collaboration
avec pop school et o'clock de structures
de formation aux métiers du numérique
ça a été de découvrir que 1 c'était
abordable que deux un certain nombre de
préjugés que l'on peut avoir sur le
numérique par exemple il faut être un
matheux pour réussir dans le numérique
ils sont rendus compte que c'était pas
le cas du tout cette initiative
participe de cette prise en main du
numérique et les métiers encore une fois
des opportunités économiques des
opportunités d'emploi qui sont derrière
qu'il ya une volonté très de
l'agglomération d'être vraiment à la
pointe sur ce sujet là parce qu'encore
une fois on prépare l'avenir l'entrée
parle notamment l'avenir de nos jeunes
une seconde édition du summer cup du
numérique pourrait être organisée
l'année prochaine